Boys and girls your attention, please. This is 99% invisible. Presenting a new exciting radio program featuring the thrilling adventures of an amazing and incredible personality. I'm Roman Mars. Faster than an airplane. More powerful than a locomotive. Impervious two-pullets. I'm in the sky. Look, it's a bird. It's a plane. It's Superman. I'm willing to concede from the get go that I might be wrong about the entire premise of this story, but Superman has never really worked for me as a character. I prefer the more grounded Marvel comic book characters like Spider-Man, who lived in real cities and had human thoughts and feelings. Superman is basically invincible, unrelatable, and who's establishment.
各位听众请注意。这里是《99%隐形》。为您呈现一档激动人心的新广播节目，讲述一位惊人且不可思议的人物所经历的惊险冒险。我是罗曼·马斯。比飞机更快。比火车更强。子弹也无法穿透。我在天空中。看，那是只鸟。那是架飞机。那是超人。我愿意从一开始就承认，我可能对这个故事的整个前提有误解，但超人作为一个角色对我来说从来没有真正奏效过。我更喜欢像蜘蛛侠那样更接地气的漫威漫画角色，他们生活在真实的城市里，有着人类的思想和情感。超人基本上是无敌的、难以产生共鸣的，而且是体制的化身。
And even though I really love the first Christopher Reeves Superman movie, it contains a perfect example of why I don't really dig the character. This is a 25 year old spoiler alert, but at the end of the 1978 movie, all the greatness of that film is nearly undone by the fundamental flaw of having a character that is all powerful when Superman flies around the earth backwards and turns back time. The first thing we got to get clear is that he's not share. He doesn't turn back time at the end of Superman 1. That's Glenn Weldon, author of Superman,
尽管我真的很喜欢第一部克里斯托弗·里夫主演的《超人》电影，但它包含了一个完美的例子，说明了我为什么不太喜欢这个角色。这是一个25年前的剧透警告，但在1978年那部电影的结尾，由于拥有一个全能角色的根本缺陷，即超人绕着地球向后飞行并让时间倒流，这部电影的所有伟大之处几乎都被抵消了。我们首先要弄清楚的是，他并没有分享。他并没有在《超人1》的结尾让时间倒流。那是格伦·韦尔登，超人的作者，
the unauthorized biography, grasping for an explanation. It's been long established in the comics that if he flies faster than the speed of light, he travels in time. So that's exactly what he's doing, except he's just spinning around and around the earth, really, really fast.
非官方传记作者，正在寻找解释。漫画中早已确定，如果他飞行的速度超过光速，他就会进行时间旅行。所以这正是他所做的，只不过他实际上只是在绕着地球一圈又一圈地飞，飞得非常非常快。
So the reason everything goes backwards is not because he's actually spinning the earth backwards on its axis, making time go backwards. We're just watching him travel back in time. We're seeing it through his eyes. So that's what's going on there. This is my Wackadoo theory that I'm gonna stand by. Firmly, despite the fact that there's some stuff in the movie that kind of contradicts it,
所以一切倒退的原因并不是因为他真的在让地球绕着地轴反向旋转，从而使时间倒流。我们只是在看他进行时间旅行。我们是通过他的眼睛看到的。这就是那里发生的事情。这是我坚持的古怪理论。尽管电影中有些东西在某种程度上与它相矛盾，但我依然坚定地支持它，
I still plow ahead further. This music that I'm talking over is from the Superman movie soundtrack. You know what it's called? It's called Turning Back the World. I'm teasing Glen Weldon because I feel like I know him because in addition to being the unauthorizedographer of Superman, he's also a panelist on NPR's pop culture happy hour podcast, which is great. It comes on on Friday.
我依然继续前行。我说话时背景里的音乐来自《超人》电影原声带。你知道它叫什么吗？它叫《让世界倒转》。我取笑格伦·韦尔登是因为我觉得我认识他，因为除了作为超人的非官方传记作者外，他还是NPR《流行文化欢乐时光》播客的嘉宾，这档节目很棒。它在周五播出。
I listen to it on Friday. So I got in touch with Glen because I thought if I can't appreciate Superman as a character, maybe I can appreciate him as a design, a supremely successful design. And the first thing Glenn told me is that I needed dispense with this notion that Superman should be relatable. The thing you have to understand about Superman is that he was never intended to be the character that we identify with. He's not a hero like Batman, he's not a hero like Spider-Man who have foibles and psychological hang-ups that we recognize and empathize with. He's not the hero we identify with. He's the hero we believe in. It's different. He's an inspiration. He's supposed to be better than us. That's right there in the name. He's called Superman for a reason. He exists to say we can be better.
我在周五听它。所以我联系了格伦，因为我想如果我不能欣赏超人这个角色，也许我可以欣赏他的设计，一个极其成功的设计。格伦告诉我的第一件事是，我需要摒弃超人应该让人产生共鸣这种想法。关于超人，你必须明白的是，他从来就不是我们认同的角色。他不像蝙蝠侠那样是英雄，他不像蜘蛛侠那样是英雄，他们有我们能识别并产生共鸣的弱点和心理障碍。他不是我们认同的英雄。他是我们信仰的英雄。这不一样。他是一种灵感。他理应比我们更好。名字里就体现了这一点。他被称为“超人”是有原因的。他的存在是为了说我们可以变得更好。
We can achieve these ideals. There are so many things that the creators of Superman, Jerry, Sequel and Joe Schuster got right in the design of Superman from the very beginning. The first thing they got right was being first, first to market. It difficult to pinpoint which character qualifies as the first superhero. It's Gilgamesh, or Hercules, or or the Phantom or the clock. It's worth looking into the clock. But Superman is certainly the first of a type that dominated popular culture
我们可以实现这些理想。超人的创作者杰里·西格尔和乔·舒斯特在超人的设计中从一开始就做对了很多事情。他们做对的第一件事就是成为第一，率先进入市场。很难确定哪个角色有资格成为第一个超级英雄。是吉尔伽美什，还是赫拉克勒斯，或者是幻影侠或时钟侠。值得研究一下时钟侠。但超人无疑是统治流行文化的那类角色中的第一个，
from the moment he debuted in 1938. And the idea was simple. Well, he was created to be basically a circus strongman. That's where the design of the costume came from. And that's what Seagal and Schuster intended. He was just like us, only bigger, stronger, better. So he could do everything that we could do, only do it more. That's where the Superman idea came from. It's very simple. That's why this character stuck around because the iconography is simple. Red, blue, and yellow, even the color blind can see. Red, blue, and yellow, that's that's important. You have to keep everything about this character as simple as possible. You couldn't fly at this point. He didn't have any of the other sensory powers. He was just a guy that Seagull and Schuster would drop into the middle of a scene with a bunch of thugs, and they would try to attack him, and he would
从他1938年首次亮相的那一刻起。这个想法很简单。嗯，他被创造出来基本上就是一个马戏团大力士。这就是服装设计的来源。这也是西格尔和舒斯特的初衷。他就像我们一样，只是更大、更强、更好。所以他能做我们能做的一切，只是做得更多。这就是超人理念的来源。非常简单。这就是为什么这个角色能留存下来，因为图标很简单。红色、蓝色和黄色，即使是色盲也能看到。红色、蓝色和黄色，这很重要。你必须让这个角色的所有东西尽可能简单。此时他还不会飞。他没有任何其他感官能力。他只是一个西格尔和舒斯特会把他扔进一群暴徒中间的家伙，他们会试图攻击他，而他会
shrug them off. This was the engine of the story. This is where the adventure, this is where the fun of those early stories came from, just him showing over and over again, that he was stronger than everybody else. So when I came to the fundamentals, Seagull and Schuster just nailed it. They did. They created something great, and everyone knew it. But as Superman endured, they had this fantastic public R&D period. They just keep uppping the ante. They kept making him bigger and more powerful and started throwing in all these other, or trying to, they started trying to throw in all these other powers,
对他们不屑一顾。这就是故事的引擎。这就是冒险所在，这就是那些早期故事的乐趣所在，只是他一次又一次地展示他比其他任何人都强。所以当谈到基本要素时，西格尔和舒斯特确实做到了。他们确实做到了。他们创造了一些伟大的东西，每个人都知道。但随着超人的持久存在，他们有了一个奇妙的公共研发期。他们只是不断提高赌注。他们不断让他变得更大、更强大，并开始加入所有这些其他的，或者试图，他们开始试图加入所有这些其他的力量，
some of which worked, some of which really didn't. One of the first weird powers he had early on was the ability to contort the muscles of his face to change his appearance and pass himself off as somebody else. Now that doesn't square with the iconography of a guy who's really better than us, who can just do what we can do only more. So it went away because it's not the power of a superhero, that's the power of a villain,
其中一些奏效了，一些确实没有。他早期拥有的第一个奇怪能力是能够扭曲面部肌肉来改变外貌，并冒充其他人。这与一个真正比我们更好、只能做我们能做的事情但做得更多的家伙的图标不符。所以它消失了，因为那不是超级英雄的力量，那是反派的力量，
it's kind of adopting somebody else's disguise so we can go undercover. It's just not that doesn't square with him. And when you have powerful enough iconography, you can make missteps like that. And it doesn't have a lasting effect. The other powers that took are things like super hearing and super vision. These things and telescopic vision, extra vision, these things are about traits that we possess that just get boosted. That's what this character is about. Later on, of course, we get things like super hypnotism and superventure
这有点像采用别人的伪装，这样我们就可以进行卧底。这与他不符。当你拥有足够强大的图标时，你可以犯这样的错误。而且它不会产生持久的影响。其他奏效的力量是超级听力和超级视力。这些东西和望远视力、透视视力，这些东西是关于我们拥有的特质，只是得到了增强。这就是这个角色的意义所在。后来，当然，我们有了超级催眠术和超级腹语术，
lequism, certain products of an age of comics called the Silver Age of Superman, when things got really weird. It happens to be my favorite era of this character because things just get bananas and Superman has become so powerful at this point that the focus starts to shift away from him onto Lois Lane, Jimmy Olson, the people around him, the super dog, the super monkey, the super cat, the super horse, all these other things around him. He becomes the patriarch of this extended family of people in Blue Lung John's. But beyond the comic book superfan, none of that stuff filtered too far out into popular culture and stuck around.
这些是被称为超人白银时代的漫画时代的产物，当时事情变得非常奇怪。这恰好是我最喜欢的这个角色的时代，因为事情变得非常疯狂，超人在这一点上变得如此强大，以至于焦点开始从他身上转移到露易丝·莱恩、吉米·奥尔森、他周围的人、超级狗、超级猴子、超级猫、超级马，他周围所有这些其他东西上。他成为了这些穿着蓝色紧身衣的人组成的大家庭的族长。但除了漫画书的超级粉丝之外，这些东西都没有太深入地渗透到流行文化中并留存下来。
The one power that did develop later, that got folded into the very core of the character, was flight. Originally he could just jump around, and on the page, that's fine. You see him in mid-air. But as soon as the Flaisher animated shorts came along, the very first couple, he jumps around like that,
后来发展出来并融入角色核心的唯一力量是飞行。最初他只能跳来跳去，在纸面上，这没问题。你看到他在半空中。但当弗莱舍动画短片出现时，最初的几部，他像那样跳来跳去，
and it looks dumb. He looks like a flea. It just doesn't work. So very soon after that, on the radio show, the sound of him jumping around became a suspended sound of wind noise. So it was clear that he was flying through the air, defying gravity.
看起来很傻。他看起来像只跳蚤。这根本行不通。所以在那之后不久，在广播节目中，他跳来跳去的声音变成了风声的悬浮声。所以很明显，他在空中飞行，无视重力。
And that's what happened in the Flicer shorts. But it took the comics a long time to agree that Yelkake can fly. Because again, the thing he could do was be better than us, but this idea of somebody being able to hover in mid-air was just too much of a break initially, from the kind of grounded, relatively grounded stories that Siegel and Schuster were telling. But once he did take to the air, once he did become a capable of flying and defying gravity, that became the thing that he's identified with.
这就是弗莱舍短片中发生的事情。但漫画花了很长时间才同意超人可以飞。因为同样，他能做的事情就是比我们更好，但这种有人能够在半空中盘旋的想法，最初与西格尔和舒斯特讲述的那种接地气的、相对接地气的故事太不协调了。但一旦他真的飞向天空，一旦他真的能够飞行并无视重力，这就成了他被认同的标志。
The tagline of the 78 film is, you will believe a man can fly, because there's something primal about that. There's something that man has always wanted to do, and so we got this guy in brilliant blue lognarons and a flying red cape who can do it. And that's what we look to him for. That's what we recognize in him now today, but it wasn't always the case. As you go through the history of Superman,
78年电影的标语是，你会相信一个人能飞，因为这其中有一些原始的东西。这是人类一直想做的事情，所以我们有了这个穿着亮蓝色紧身衣和红色斗篷的家伙，他能做到。这就是我们向他寻求的东西。这就是我们今天在他身上认同的东西，但这并不总是这样。当你回顾超人的历史时，
England Walden's book, you find a character that adapts in strange ways to reflect the zeitgeist and anxieties of the time. But certain qualities get written into Superman's DNA that form the real basis of what makes Superman Superman. And it has nothing to do with the way he looks. Ultimately, what I found over the course of the writing the book is that a lot of this stuff comes and goes, the red shorts can come and go, the spit curl goes away, it comes back. He
格伦·韦尔登的书，你会发现一个以奇怪方式适应以反映时代精神和焦虑的角色。但某些品质被写入了超人的DNA中，构成了让超人成为超人的真正基础。这与他的外表无关。最终，我在写书的过程中发现，很多东西来来去去，红短裤可以来来去去，卷发消失了，又回来了。他
gets a different costume, he gets this weird electrical blue costume in the 90s, everything cycles. But it's not what he looks like, even though that is considered the iconography of this character. Not what he looks like that makes him super mad. It is what he does and why he does it. Number one, he puts the needs of others over those of himself and be he doesn't give up. So those two elements, if either one of those two elements are missing, are brain instinctively rejects it.
换了不同的服装，他在90年代穿上了这种奇怪的电蓝色服装，一切都在循环。但这不是他的样子，尽管这被认为是这个角色的图标。让他成为超人的不是他的样子。而是他做什么以及为什么这样做。第一，他把别人的需求置于自己之上，并且他不会放弃。所以这两个要素，如果这两个要素中任何一个缺失，我们的大脑本能地拒绝它。
It doesn't feel like a Superman story for some reason. Which makes telling, compelling, and nuanced Superman stories pretty difficult. But while Nargis, that nuance is not what Superman is about. We've reached a cynical age where we don't trust altruism. That's what he's there for. He's there to represent it. He's there to say, here's truth. Here's what it looks like. Here's justice. here's what it looks like. Here's compassion,
出于某种原因，它感觉不像超人故事。这使得讲述引人入胜且细致入微的超人故事变得非常困难。但虽然纳吉斯，这种细微差别不是超人的意义所在。我们已经进入了一个愤世嫉俗的时代，我们不信任利他主义。这就是他存在的意义。他代表了它。他在这里说，这是真相。这就是它的样子。这是正义。这就是它的样子。这是同情心，
which is a big part of him. And also, you know, he's called the Man of Tomorrow because that's been part of his DNA from the beginning. He's called the Man of Tomorrow long before he was called the Man of Steel. It was his original nickname, basically, because he helped point the way to the future to say, here's what we can be. Here's, if we're better to each other and better to ourselves, here's what we can do. So that's, it's easy. I'm a pretty cynical douchebag in most of my life, and this one area about this character, I don't know, I believe in him. ... 99% Invisible is Sam Greenspan and me Roman Mars. Special thanks to Jess Gettner from the NPR for recording Glenn Wellton for us.
这是他很大的一部分。而且，你知道，他被称为“明日之人”，因为从一开始这就是他DNA的一部分。在他被称为“钢铁之躯”很久之前，他就被称为“明日之人”。这基本上是他最初的绰号，因为他帮助指明了通往未来的道路，说，这就是我们可以成为的样子。这就是，如果我们对彼此更好，对自己更好，这就是我们能做到的。所以这，这很容易。我在生活中大部分时间都是一个相当愤世嫉俗的混蛋，但在关于这个角色的这个领域，我不知道，我相信他。……《99%隐形》由萨姆·格林斯潘和我罗曼·马斯制作。特别感谢NPR的杰斯·格特纳为我们录制了格伦·韦尔登。
We are a project of 91.7 Local Public Radio KALW in San Francisco and the American Institute of Architects in San Francisco. You can find the show and like the show on Facebook. I tweet at Roman Mars, but you can always catch up with us online at 99%invisible.org. Radio Tepio from PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们是旧金山91.7地方公共广播电台KALW和旧金山美国建筑师协会的一个项目。你可以在Facebook上找到这个节目并点赞。我在推特上叫罗曼·马斯，但你总是可以在99%invisible.org在线收听我们的节目。来自PRX的广播电台。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。